this is off-the-record on-the-record
right I may or may not have ad the
letter D spray-painted on my high school
well I've never mad at to do what's up
guys my name is curly today we were
hanging out with my new favorite people
for my new favorite series on Looking
for Alaska I'm Sofia vasilieva and I
play a lot of witches Gaia that accent
I'm Ranger bender and I play Sarah
Harvard I'm Vinny love I play chip
Martin aka the colonel I'm Jay Lee I
play Takumi you coquito I'm obsessed
with you guys fried episode 2 there's a
scene with y'all two together where I
legit was just like that is so beautiful
it got me thinking about where I was in
high school and who I was then in who I
am now and advice that I would give my
stuff watching y'all be these young
people on the show what advice would you
have for yourself it's a nice cool I
think just just important to be it's
hard because you want to be like be
yourself but you don't really know who
you are at this point you're still
trying to figure self out the more you
let your fear stop you especially when
you're younger the more and a habit that
becomes did y'all have like crushes on
anybody in high and high scores my crush
I was never able to get because she was
a teacher and their name's miss Euler is
my Spanish teacher Wow you're 26 now hey
oh my god no no don't miss that miss
Euler Oh question on everybody when we
were younger like is that uh no because
I I was the annoying 14 year old that
was like I want a genuine connection
with like another human being and all
these people are superficial I never
pranked well I was thinking about this
and I can't I couldn't think of any
pranks I almost pulled a bunch of pranks
on this set but they never happens this
would be right for every single person I
was the kid that went to Staples and
spent like way too much money on every
highlighter every like whoo I'm jealous
I was gonna say that
my favorite thing was that that first
outfit yeah that's a big deal yo first
outfit when you lay out them pants and
that shirt for the neck look at it and
then day 2 you just go back to sweat
pants yeah I found that none of the
arguments I got into were like ending
friendships which we're good like they
were kind of like oh my god this is
annoying let's chat about it this sucks
and then you know an hour later you're
kind of over it yeah so now I want to
talk to guys about being the new kid
have you ever been a new kid anywhere I
was in the beginning but I was always
the new kid really I moved around a lot
with my parents it's a really cool
opportunity to learn a lot and see a lot
and so like picking up and moving even
though it's scary if you still get to
keep all the friends you had before and
then you get to have new friends that
you gather along the way much like
Connor the kernel takes Pudge into his
world and like shows him the ropes I
think it's super important that you
kinda have a person that guy show you
around you guys I am so excited for
y'all I'm so happy for each every one of
you this show is fantastic it's so good
so much I'm like kidding for you guys ah
everybody else to watch it when can they
watch it
[Applause]